I was chosen for the female Protection
Team four years ago I can't express how
excited I was it was my dream and the
dream comes true I'm first carpeted
omnia doll with stamen I'm working in
Dubai police in security emergency and
proc tech department the pioneering
all-female elite squads role is to
protect visiting VIPs at the big events
in the UAE their training includes
hand-to-hand combat firearms and the
kind of driving skills that put
Hollywood stuntmen to shame these women
have safeguarded over 500 VIPs on more
than 1,000 occasions for 30 a female in
the unit and there's different teams we
have the bikers and the drivers I'm one
of the bikers these highly skilled women
go through rigorous training and only
the very best can hope to earn a place
in the elite squad but from yet law
enforcement is more than just her job I
decided to be a police officer when I
was 16 years old my mom and most of my
family members are in place and as well
in their army I ambition solemn of
dilemma my rank is a major I was one of
the first women of a certain type honest
when my daughter became part of the VIP
production unit I was so proud
why granddaughter she also liked to be
to this it will be three generation me
it's not hard to see the appeal these
women have an important and exciting
role here and although it's a demanding
and disciplined life working and living
in this 21st century city has its own
reward
I love devar and if
whether they're our VIP or regular
person they have to feel safe in the way
now we will keep helping them because we
are the protection team
[Music]